the Biden Administration seems to be
asking for is billions of additional
dollars with no appropriate oversight no
clear strategy to win and and none of
the answers that I think the American
people are owed here's Mike Johnson
after meeting with zalinski saying that
Ukraine funding has to be tied to border
security meaning if we're going to give
you some freaking money uh how about we
can actually do a little something for
the citizens of America how Noble we
need a clear articulation of the
strategy to allow Ukraine to win
and thus far their responses have been
insufficient they have not provided us
the clarity and the detail that we have
requested over and over since literally
24 hours after I was handed the gavl as
Speaker of the House and so what the
Biden Administration seems to be asking
for is billions of additional dollars
with no appropriate oversight no clear
strategy to win and and none of the
answers that I think the American people
are owed I have also made very clear
from day one that our first condition on
any national security supplement
spending package is about our own
National Security First the border is an
absolute catastrophe and this is because
of the policies of this white house and
this Administration we had 12,000
illegal Crossings on one day last week
alone on Wednesday we have uh almost now
280 known terrorists that have been
apprehended at the border none of this
counts the getaways if you add the
numbers up it's almost 7 million people
who have been encountered at the border
just since President Biden took office
and at least 2 million got aways this is
twice the population in my state of
Louisiana fentel is the leading cause of
death for Americans age 18 to 49 in this
country fentel poisoning because it's
allowed over the Border we have human
trafficking and all the other terrible
things in the last three months October
November December alone we've had more
illegal Crossings at the border than in
any entire year dur during the Obama
Administration the American people see
this they feel it acutely they see all
the Terrible societal ills that come
from this and it must be addressed so I
made this very clear again from the very
beginning when I was hand of the gavl we
needed Clarity on what we're doing in
Ukraine and how we'll have proper
oversight of the spending of precious
taxpayer dollars of the American
citizens and we needed a transformative
change at the border you really need to
think about this and it it does maybe
you're watching this and I'm a little
more isolationist on Ukraine and again I
just think that that from the beginning
you've seen what I've said about this
there was mission creep we don't know
who the good guys and bad guys are as
I've talked about many times I had Ram
Paul and we don't know where the money's
going like there's just like Putin's got
nukes like there's a whole bunch of
series of problems there by the way I
would say that's starkly different than
what's going on with Israel and Gaza
because there's a very clear wind there
which is the toppling of uh Hamas and
then actually setting a border and
helping an ally who helps us with
technology and all sorts of stuff but
that that's that's a complete aside um
but he's basically making two clear
points could you tell us what the plan
is if we're going to give them billions
of dollars that's number one and how
about we do a little something at home
first how many of those videos do we
play each week where we just have people
pouring through our border no one that
could even approximately consider
themselves pro- America could think that
that's okay the Democrat Party thinks
it's okay and the people of CNN and
MSNBC think it's okay because I don't
think they're very Pro America that's
kind of where we're at at the
moment